توسع روسيا دائره المواجهات بعد ان كانت
مركزه في منطقه دوم بس وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه قالت انها توغلت سبعه كيلو مترات
داخل زبوريجيا
اتخذت وحدات المنطقه العسكريه الشرقيه
خطوط النوى مواقع متميزه
الهجمات الروسيه كما طالت الهجمات منطقه
سومي قرب الحدود مع روسيا وفيما يتعلق
باحراز تقدم الروسيه اعتبر مسؤولون
عسكريون اوكرانيون ذلك مجرد مبالغات بحسب
المختصين العسكريين يسعروس من خلال تنويع
الجبهات لانهاج الدفاعات الاخرانيه
واحده من اربع مناطق اوكرانيه اعلن افلامي
قبل عده اشهر ضمها الى ميلاده من دون ان
تكون اصلا خاضعه باكملها للسيطره الروسيه
ونشرت صور حديثه لتاجر سلاح الروسي فيكتور
بوت يزور المناطق المحتله
وكان ب تخرج من السجن في الولايات المتحده
قبل اسابيع فقط بموجب صفقه تبادل للاسرى
بين موسكو واشنطن
شخص اخر من عالم العسكر الموازي في روسيا
صار يظهر الى العالم وهو يفجني بروجين
مؤسس مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه الخاصه الذي
اعلن في وقت سابق من الشهر الحالي
الاستلاء على بلده سوليدار الاوكرانيه
وافاد موقع تابع لمجموعه فاكنر انها تعتزم
ارسال جثه جنود اوكرانيين الى مناطق خاضعه
لسلطتك كيافه بالمقابل يؤكد الجيش
الاوكراني ايضا انه كبد الروس خسائر فادحه
في سوريا
المتزايده تريد اوكرانيا دبابات متطوره
واعرضت عن اسفها لتردد الدول الغربيه
خصوصا المانيا في تلبيه مطلبها